we have a story right now that i saw
this yesterday and i said guys we have
to cover it and they said are you sure
dave is this is this the type of thing
we want to cover on this program and i
said we have to cover this this is
important this is vital people need to
know about this and we have to talk
about it so that it doesn't happen again
here's a tweet from the new york post
arnold schwarzenegger deliberately
farted in my face
act actress claims
the woman being pictured there by the
way uh i'm told is only 23 years old but
that's what happened to her after uh
schwarzenegger farted in her face we've
got some more uh information from usa
today on exactly what happened there
this is very important stuff people
actress miriam margulies knows how to
hold a grudge opening up about a foul
experience she had with former co-star
arnold schwarzenegger more than two
decades ago during an appearance on the
i've got news for you podcast monday
margulies was asked by host andrew
bucklow if there were any celebrity
co-stars she didn't enjoy working with
over the course of her nearly 60-year
career the harry potter actress
immediately brought up schwarzenegger
saying she didn't care for him she
explained he's a bit too full of himself
margulies and schwarzenegger co-starred
in 1999's at end of days an apocalyptic
horror film about an ex-cop's quest to
thwart satan's search for a bride
margulies revealed schwarzenegger was
rude to her on set and that they had an
unpleasant encounter while filming
he farted in my face margulies told
bucklow now i fart of course i do but i
don't fart in people's faces he did it
deliberately right in my face
so you see
this is what's happening in society okay
and i think we can link this directly to
uh the progressives because you know
arnold schwarzenegger was a republican
governor in california and now he's
pretty much a democrat and what so you
know you just start farting on people's
faces
i don't know exactly why we did that
story i just felt we had to people
needed to know people needed to know
because you know what it is i guess it's
the metaphor the left has been farting
in all of our faces and we have accepted
it
but that's it people we are not going to
let them fart in our face anymore
literally
or
figuratively